and the numbers the numbers back it up
because if a man has more partners it
doesn't really affect his marital
happiness not by a lot but if a woman if
she's slept with if she's a virgin when
she gets married she has an 80 chance of
having a happy marriage if you've slept
with more than five people you have a
less than 25 percent chance of ever
getting married or having a happy
marriage just over five people
so so it's like
because you're allowed is that because
of the comparison is that because women
are comparing it well and it's also
linked to higher it's linked to higher
rates of depression on top of that
um
but and women married in their mid-20s
when they've never lived with a guy have
the lowest rates of divorce
because could you imagine like if two
virgins got together
that's the idea
that's the highest rates is when two
birds virgins get together and yeah the
marriage probably lasts forever because
you don't have anything to compare
correct two this is your relationship
women are hypergamous so it's like it's
like it goes back to the alpha widow
effect because if a girl experienced a
guy that's say she's 22 okay then she
she gets with a guy that's an eight
like one to ten he's an eight in terms
of like status money whatev whatever she
looks for in values then now she's 30
right she's less attractive maybe she's
gained a little weight maybe she has a
kid then she can't get the guy that's an
eight anymore so she ends up marrying
the guy that's a five and she's always
thinking about the guy that's eight yeah
and so it's not the case for every woman
there's girls that are exceptions
there's a girl that's so marry up but
we're talking in general like most girls
don't like the best they can do is in
their like early to mid 20s
there was a there's actually a netflix
um
series that was on i don't know what's
called sex life or something where this
is woman who had this perfect life
and she was married to a perfect man
but prior to being with this perfect man
and having his perfect life with his
perfect children the white picket fence
and the whole thing she was with this
bad boy right and this bad boy was
[ __ ] her down like no one ever [ __ ]
her down right so she's got this perfect
life and she kept on thinking about this
guy she she couldn't get out of her
system and then eventually she went back
and
and and i see it i see like i mean i ask
this question to girls all the time you
ever have a friend that has that one ax
they can't get over they might be dating
the new guy or another new guy but they
keep thinking about that one x and i see
it all the time in girls
and
like it's just it's just it's
unfortunate because i think society lies
to us and says there's no consequences
for that but
like there definitely are
i think when women become happy they
become bored
sometimes yeah i think a lot of the time
they become bored i think
a lot of women just want something a
little bit more
turmoil it's more interesting
curiosity curiosity kills the cat but i
think there's different things that you
can do in your relationship that
stops the boredom no
yeah there are just women often choose
not to do them
because we leave we leave 70 to 80 of
the time if we're college educated it's
a 90.
when men aren't the ones leaving it's
women and i think when a woman sleeps
around it's the biggest damage she does
to herself because a man's not like a
lot you can get away like you move a
guy's not really going to know who you
slept with but like mentally
i feel like you can't turn a hoe into a
housewife because she's always going to
want to go back to the streets
and you see it with sierra what happened
with her
like sierra like what would happen she
she marries she's you know going around
with the rapper he's wild and out he has
his kid
marries russell westbrook perfect guy
who who here would like
super good he's got everything you would
want in a husband and now and now he's
he's boring yeah so a lot of women yeah
but i'm saying as a husband great but
like what's she doing now she's wilding
out on instagram shaking her out like
how disrespectful is that this man wifed
you yeah i haven't seen that is that
what she's doing now yeah but why would
can i just ask why would russell be
boring i don't understand oh i mean not
to us yeah but it's like some girls when
they just prefer the rappers like
they're exciting
yeah they prefer that exciting guy
that's gonna you know so you're saying
if you were to marry man like russell
and he's he looks conservative and calm
and quiet that you should also replicate
that
if you were someone that was like
not a hoe but
just out there well your partner is a
reflection of you
so it's like if i'm going to get with a
woman and i'm kind of
cool and conservative oh my god is that
sierra now does that sierra and the
white and the blue hair
yeah yeah that's what i was talking
about at the galaxy
she's got a whole husband and then she's
got here and then she goes and she's got
kids
and the whole world is seeing that
that's my woman and
everyone can see her ass i'm sorry i
she's letting us know that she's got her
what
hush her what [ __ ] she's like she's got
basically what i'm trying to say is that
she's letting the world know that she's
a guy yeah i'm a mom she has a wife but
she's whole but you know
so what like yeah you know but you know
it is for me like as a mother you have
to put yourself to the side like you're
a mother now i just i saw the video
and i do believe that you know as a
mummy
[Music]
you make like sacrifices in a lot of
ways and that's part of motherhood but
then gets to a point where your child is
now grown and they're their own
individual adult so they're watching her
children
no no but i'm saying her kids
her kids are young like her children are
young so what example are you kind of
sitting as a as a mom you see it now a
lot as well with like young girls and
stuff
they got
they've got weaves and nails and
stuff like that sorry i really sit in
here
but it's it's i mean it's it's selfish
and that's the thing like modern modern
women are selfish because
because they're putting themselves above
their children and that's what she's
doing you you know you know how
embarrassing that is to have your mom
twerking as a kid even you could be 10
15 like even if i to this day if my mom
put that on the internet i would be so
embarrassed
like you're you're putting yourself
above your kids are you seeing it in a
more traditional aspect
or i'm seeing it like right and wrong i
don't think it's tradition
if she was a regular if she was a
regular woman
people were saying how could she do that
that's that's her wish behavior she
shouldn't be doing that she has kids but
but because she see era i think she
people are giving her more of a pass
what if what is that what if the dad was
going to strip clubs and posting that
post it exactly i mean what would we be
able to do about it i mean nothing but
like that would be that would be
disrespectful it would be disrespectful
like what she's doing there she's
disrespecting her husband attention from
other man what else are you putting that
on the internet the way i see it is
sierra was a dancer
she wasn't just a singer she was
actually a dancer so
i mean maybe the twerking is a bit
because me as a mother i don't agree
with that i don't even mean i don't like
to look wild
like i like to have fun don't get me
wrong but i think there's a level of
that why don't you ask me to be out yeah
she could still do like a dance routine
but no i think like maybe because she
was a dancer and she's a performer
it's like people are taking the twerking
as like
she's twerking for attention but
sometimes people don't necessarily twerk
for attention we are grown adults we
know exactly what the internet is like
we know exactly how many people are
gonna watch it we know exactly where
it's gonna go stuff could go viral
like let's not play dumb wait wait do we
know where actual booty shaking came
from
beauty shaking i mean yeah do i care yes
yes you should in in what aspect
because beauty shaking actually if
you're going to see the cultural aspect
it's in our blood it's in our blood like
if i was going to shake my arse now to a
song that is from my tribe
you
i would say it's more of a cultural
people in the states it's not a culture
since that's something that i've noticed
that
in africa it's just
in you and like here you all know where
y'all roots are from and everything and
it's in you to do that because it's a
part of you in the states it's just
something that oh it's twerking we call
it twerking it's ratchet behavior
yeah they're away sorry to call you no
no you're good and
it's like we
we look at it as something different and
elsewhere it is a part of the culture it
is like cultural to do that and it's not
it's not un normal to see a little kid
doing it because
it's just
it's not a
sexual dance move for
other cultures but in the states it is
deemed that way but you know why it's
deemed that way in the states because
when you sorry to say but when you guys
were taken to the states you were
already stripped of everything that you
came with
so
if you came with your culture your
language your your you couldn't even
wear your clothes that you came with so
in reality it's like you just don't have
that culture because it was taken away
from you that's why it would be seen as
wrong
can i ask you a question sorry um are
you ladies saying that twerking isn't
sexual no no no
what exactly are we arguing yeah because
like i think it's not sexual
yeah
because i've seen sierra
yeah you may say she's a dancer and
that's fair enough
um
but she's a performer
or
was a performer and she's shaking her
ass and she has kids
and
for me it's like it just reiterates that
you can't wife a hoe because they will
always go back once they've secured what
they need to secure and like you're
you're kind of saying it's okay no i'm
not saying it's okay you guys because
you're making excuses with that you're
saying
then why bring up the culture if it's
not an excuse because my point is i feel
like twerking has become a thing that
has become it's an exaggerated form of
people's culture it's like it's been
exaggerated and made to look bad and
that's why it looks bad on her that's i
mean you won't catch me twerking because
that's just not about me but i'll shake
my ass yeah i'll enjoy my dance but
different i just feel like
it's
when when it comes to twerking it's so
quick to be like oh she's she's so she's
disgusting she's wrong don't don't you
know i'm not saying
it's excusable
but i just think that like
for me it's just this whole thing of
women are wrong women are ruined are
wrong she's wrong for twerking but like
we said if her husband went to the strip
club and it was shown on the internet it
would be like oh
but there we go in context with the with
the twerking right no um there are many
there are many african cultures that do
it
um when you're single
and women do it in a setting
to show their vital their their
what's their assets are they know their
virility yeah and to show that they are
of childbearing age they they look
they're going to be their wife
right
once that's done
lock down time yeah once once you show
he locks you down this generation or
this culture
married single they're just doing it so
there's a difference in the culture so
it's like there can be um into places
like even places in south africa or west
africa where there are rituals and there
are dance rituals where men will say
okay the women will come around and show
who the single one is and men will kind
of pick and they will dance cool and
then they get taken that's it i don't
think it's necessarily all single
because you get older ladies who um
there are older ladies who will
shake but like why does it matter when
in the us that's not the culture so
she's not doing it because of the
culture
i mean she's doing it because it's a
dance and she's enjoying herself so
she's doing it because she's a thot and
she's for the streets
grew up on sierra leone you gotta
remember she portrays what she wants us
to know and see that's right
same like beyonce said it word for word
like i will give you what i want to give
you well that's what hoes do they
portray their body that they want you to
see
um like so are you saying that if you
were married to a man
and you were doing that he wouldn't find
that disrespectful if you found me
shake your mouth
like that like that sierra video
he would have found it in booty
if that's how you found me
and that's how you like you that was
what you're attracted to he didn't find
her like that do you not remember after
the future after future she came with
the whole church vibe i'm i've changed
my ways i've done all of that i'm now a
new person he found her in like the
church kind of format
then they had kids
then she was being the wife that america
always wanted and now she's gone back so
he didn't find her like that she's doing
the megan good but he knew who she was
before oh one good is a difference no
she's doing a megan good good that one
i'd
well i know but this is what what he's
saying is that reinforces that men can't
wife hoes they can't wife girls with
past because they will always go back to
the streets
once they've had the streets they always
go back to the streets and they'll put
they're so selfish that they'll put
their feelings and their need for
attention above their children
you're supposed to love more than
anything in the world i would i would
never want to put my kids in a position
where they would be embarrassed like
that
just look at kim look at him like
she she became a mother and then she
started crying about how
her sex tape got leaked
only to find out that she and her family
are the ones that leaked her sex tape
again and and she didn't have kids then
but you know you're gonna have kids
and and so that's that's what i like
when i'm posting today i always think
what i want my future kids to see this